[Aplausos]
[Música]
si os hablo de una isla europea dividida
en dos partes antigua colonia británica
en la que se conduce por la izquierda y
cuya economía ha crecido enormemente en
los últimos años en qué país estáis
pensando seguro que muchos diréis que
irlanda
pues no hay otra isla de la que no se
habla tanto que reúne exactamente estas
mismas características queridos amigos
de visual política en este vídeo vamos a
hablar de chipre una isla mediterránea
donde hace bastante más calorcito que en
irlanda pero que también tiene su
territorio partido en dos
[Música]
la historia que se conozca habitualmente
pero la isla de chipre encontramos dos
estados diferentes el de la república de
chipre y el de la constituida república
turca del norte de chipre que solamente
reconocida como país soberano por
turquía de esta forma la parte sur está
plenamente integrada en la unión europea
mientras que la parte norte está
integrada a las redes políticas y
comerciales de turquía con lo cual como
podéis imaginar las diferencias
políticas y económicas son enormes
ahora bien seguro que muchos os estaréis
preguntando pero cómo terminó esta
pequeña isla del mediterráneo dividida
en dos que es eso de la república turca
del norte de chipre pues bien en este
vídeo vamos a contestar a estas y a
otras preguntas atentos
[Música]
chipre una herida del gran imperio
no es algo extraño en muchas de las
colonias del antiguo imperio británico
el gran imperio británico la
descolonización trajo consigo muchos
problemas étnicos y territoriales este
caso fue uno más de tantos
chipre fue entregada al reino unido- a
modo de protectorado después de un
acuerdo con el imperio otomano a finales
del siglo 19 se le cedió el control de
la isla como agradecimiento por el apoyo
que los británicos habían prestado a los
otomanos en su guerra contra rusia sin
embargo no fue hasta el estallido de la
primera guerra mundial en 1914 cuando el
reino unido- declaró como colonia a
chipre
ahora bien como fue este dominio
colonial porque finalizó como afectó a
la historia chipriota
pues lo cierto es que la colonización de
chipre no es que fuera exactamente lo
que se dice un mar en calma veréis
muchos chipriotas especialmente aquellos
de etnia griega rechazaban frontalmente
el dominio colonial y ahora que se
habían librado del imperio otomano
apostaban por anexionar la isla a grecia
algo que se conoce como enosis
tal y como os podéis imaginar esta
posibilidad fue algo que nunca les hizo
demasiada gracia a los chipriotas de
origen turco que por supuesto no se
sentían nada pero que nada identificados
con grecia hablamos de un enfrentamiento
que alimentó numerosas revueltas que en
algún caso tuvieron que llegar a ser
sofocadas por las fuerzas británicas
ahora bien el mayor de los problemas
la confrontación definitiva comenzó tras
la independencia en 1960
[Música]
la confrontación por el poder entre la
comunidad griega y la comunidad turca
llegó a tal punto que apenas tres años
después de la independencia en 1963 la
violencia estalló esta situación condujo
que turquía amenazar a con intervenir
militarmente la isla para proteger a los
turco chipriotas
finalmente eeuu logró evitar esa
posibilidad pero la mecha no había hecho
nada más que empezar a aprender
tras años con periodos intermitentes de
inestabilidad y calma tensa en el 74 un
golpe de estado controlado desde atenas
derrocó al gobierno del arzobispo
makarios tercero y desencadenó sólo
cinco días después la invasión del norte
de chipre por parte de turquía
y así fue amigos como se trazó una
división que llega hasta nuestros días y
que formalmente se materializó en 1983
con la creación unilateral del estado de
la república turca del norte de chipre
un país de apenas 300 mil habitantes que
sólo reconoce como tal turquía y que 36
años después de su independencia carece
incluso de himnos
[Música]
el caso es que esto es lo que explica
que en esta isla encontremos una ciudad
la capital nicosia dividida en dos por
un muro al más puro estilo del berlín de
la guerra fría pero os gustaría saber
cómo vive hoy chipre la división
nacional y qué queda de las tensiones
del pasado que podemos encontrar si
vamos a nicosia la capital chipriota
pues amigos prestar atención porque
resulta sorprendente
nicosia la última capital dividida de
europa pasear por algunas zonas de
nicosia es hoy lo más parecido a caminar
por el viejo berlín /
[Música]
en muchas calles especialmente las de la
antigua ciudad amurallada de nicosia se
levantan barreras vallas y muros hechos
con barriles rellenos de hormigón
[Música]
es la separación entre la nicosia
grecochipriota y turcochipriota una
separación que deja entre ambas una
franja desmilitarizada completamente
abandonada y controlada por la onu
conocida como la línea verde
[Música]
esta línea se extiende de extremo a
extremo por toda la isla y es una zona
desmilitarizada al más puro estilo
coreano que en su lado más ancho alcanza
los 7 km de anchura y supone en total el
3% del territorio de la isla
[Música]
pero es en nicosia donde la línea verde
realmente es más apreciable allí es
donde se sucedieron los peores
enfrentamientos entre ambas comunidades
durante la segunda mitad del siglo 20
[Música]
en la capital la franja parece más bien
un lugar donde se ha detenido el tiempo
y testigo de ese pasado convulso está
por ejemplo el antiguo aeropuerto
[Música]
una instalación completamente abandonada
desde el año 1974 si desde el golpe de
estado y la posterior invasión turca
[Música]
un aeropuerto que en la actualidad solo
sirve para que algunos puñados de
turistas pasen a hacerse fotos en las
viejas salas de espera y en las corro y
las cintas de facturación de estilo
sesentero que parecen sacadas de toda
una película apocalíptica
[Música]
desde luego que para los amantes de
turismo negro debe ser un must porque
las imágenes que te puedes llevar de
este lugar son impresionantes y esto no
es todo
gracias
[Música]
en los viejos talleres y concesionarios
de coches de la línea verde nicosia se
pueden ver los viejos modelos importados
y abandonados que nadie ha tocado desde
el 74 ven hay bares restaurantes y casas
abandonadas donde todavía se pueden ver
las viejas botellas de coca-cola sobre
la mesa hay heridas de bala en sus
fachadas
[Música]
pero amigos no es que sólo hablemos de
una franja abandonada aunque durante los
últimos años se ha suavizado la división
va mucho pero que mucho más allá
a pesar de encontrarse en pleno
mediterráneo la república turca del
norte de chipre es uno de los lugares
más aislados del planeta no ha sido
reconocida por nadie y ha estado bajo
sanciones internacionales durante las
últimas cuatro décadas
desde el punto de vista internacional su
único acceso es turquía sus habitantes
carecen de pasaporte propio y por
ejemplo incluso el establecimiento de
marcas y franquicias internacionales
está prohibido en todos los niveles
económicas social y políticamente es
como si no existiéramos vivimos en un
país donde el contacto regular con el
resto del mundo está severamente
comprometido o zilina mi representante
especial turco chipriota en las
negociaciones para resolver la disputa
de chipre de hecho no fue hasta el año
2003 cuando se relajaron algunas
restricciones y la línea verde se pudo
atravesar por primera vez en más de 30
años
ahora bien llegados a este punto la
pregunta que podemos hacernos es cuál
puede ser la solución para chipre podría
esta división terminar pronto
[Música]
si nos fijamos en los antecedentes lo
cierto es que parece difícil aunque el
mismísimo secretario general de las
naciones unidas esté empeñado en
conseguirlo
[Música]
antonio guterres se ha propuesto como
uno de los retos de su secretaria ni más
ni menos que un acuerdo para reunificar
chipre bajo un sistema federal bicomunal
y bizonal y para esto este año el 2020
podría ser o bien un año clave o bien
otro año más en la larga lista de
fracasos diplomáticos en chipre
este momento la onu se ha marcado como
objetivo volver a reanudar las
negociaciones a mediados del 2020 la onu
elogia las conversaciones francas de
chipre y promete reiniciar el esfuerzo
de paz sin embargo amigos lo cierto es
que en los últimos años se ha presentado
un nuevo protagonista que ha hecho que
la cuestión chipriota resulte aún mucho
más complicada atentos la reunificación
un camino imposible cuando algo se rompe
volverlo a unir resulta muy complicado y
desde luego si hablamos de países
entonces puede resultar casi una misión
imposible eso es exactamente lo que
ocurre en chipre aunque las diferencias
entre las dos comunidades se han
reducido enormemente todavía quedan
barreras difíciles de franquear qué
ocurrirá con las tropas turcas si
tenemos en cuenta que los
turcochipriotas viven básicamente de
ellas como se resolverá el tema de las
propiedades que incautó
a los propietarios grecochipriotas cómo
se organizarán políticamente las dos
comunidades para que una no quede bajo
el control de la otra como se repartirá
en el territorio que ocurrirá con la
política social financiera acaso el sur
el desarrollo de servicios e
infraestructuras en el norte que es
mucho más pobre y junto a todas estas
preguntas hay también un nuevo problema
geoestratégico que amenaza de muerte a
las propias negociaciones chipre se
encuentra en estos momentos en medio de
una encrucijada comercial y económica
que no es del agrado de turquía y aunque
la república turca del norte de chipre
es en teoría sobre el papel un país
independiente lo cierto es que turquía
es quien se encarga de que los intereses
del norte de chipre vayan alineados con
los suyos sobre todo en cuestiones de
política internacional
al fin y al cabo para eso es el único
país en reconocer a esta república al
tiempo que mantiene a más de 30 mil
soldados desplegados en la isla el caso
es que es aquí cuando nos topamos de
bruces con un nuevo escollo en forma de
tubo largo y grueso por debajo del mar
ni más ni menos que del gaseoducto
eastman el ist met es un gasoducto cuya
construcción podría comenzar muy pronto
y que servirá para que israel pueda
exportar gas directamente a europa en el
año 2025 israel y chipre que por su lado
también ha comenzado a explotar sus
reservas de gas en el mar
de niño
y es que amigos de visual político como
ya os contamos aquí en este canal israel
ha conseguido disparar su producción de
gas hasta conseguir cifras de producción
muy significativas
de hecho hace muy poquito tiempo el 2 de
enero de 2020 vamos prácticamente ayer
se dio un paso de gigante para la
realización de este proyecto líderes de
israel chipre y grecia firman el acuerdo
del gasoducto ismet ahora bien la gran
pregunta porque esto puede suponer un
problema de cara a conversaciones sobre
la reunificación chipriotas
pues simple y llanamente porque esto
choca frontalmente con los intereses
geoestratégicos y económicos de turquía
por donde discurre el gasoducto que
conduce hoy el gas exportado desde
oriente medio' hasta europa una
situación que le otorga a turquía el
poder de controlar el paso de un
suministro vital para un continente que
últimamente ya no es tan amigo del
régimen turco
el resto de la historia ya os lo
imagináis verdad pues bien si a todo
esto le sumamos que es israel israel el
principal beneficiado con este proyecto
pues la cosa se pone aún más complicada
porque amigos ultimamente turquía israel
se llevan peor que batman y el joker
[Música]
así que he visto lo visto si la
ramificación ya era difícil con este
nuevo enfrentamiento entre turquía y
chipre parece mucho más complicada en
fin amigos así es como están las cosas
hoy por hoy en chipre pero ahora turno
para ti conocías la república turca del
norte de chipre crees que estos dos
estados tienen que reunificarse o por
contra deberían mantener su
independencia déjanos tus impresiones en
los comentarios y ya sabéis si este
vídeo os ha resultado interesante no
olvidéis darle al botón de like un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]